depuis un siècle
cet animal géant parcours les plaines de
notre imagination
mais aujourd'hui deux nouveaux fossiles
pose une question hérétiques t-rex et
est il qu'une machine mésozoïque
destinés au ramassage des détritus la
science pourrait-elle nous apporter
d'autres désillusions sur notre monstre
favorite
[Musique]
don
aucun dinosaures ne s'est jamais emparé
de l'imagination populaire comme le
tyrannosaurus rex
[Musique]
célébrité internationale il est devenu
le symbole de la destruction et d'une
terreur qui glace le sang
[Musique]
le portrait qu'a fait hollywood t-rex et
celui d'un animal insatiable et
incontrôlable l'ultime prédateurs
[Musique]
et
il est devenu le best seller des
dinosaures cdh en plastique sont vendus
comme souvenir oil deux fait des copies
de t-rex en métal elles répondent à
l'image du monstre que le public
souhaite légendaire pour sa férocité rex
montent la garde à travers tout le pays
devant les motels les glaciers et dans
les jardins publics
[Musique]
sa taille fait peur trois fois la taille
d'un homme
il pesait jusqu'à 70
sa mâchoire aux muscles puissants
étaient garnies de dents de 22 cm
mais le pire est que ce gigantesque
animal se nourrissait de viande
c'est le plus grand carnivore avoir
jamais foulé le sol
la présence de t-rex dans les musées du
monde entier fait croire qu'on en a
découvert de nombreux fossiles mais la
vérité est que la plus grande partie des
tyrannosaurus exposées sont des moulages
fait à partir de quelques fossiles mise
à jour t-rex a régné sur terre pendant 2
millions d'années mais jusqu'à une date
récente sa réputation n'était fondée que
sur neuf spécimens incomplet et tous ont
été extraits des étendues sauvages qui
vont du wyoming et du montana
jusqu au dakota du sud et au canada de
l'ouest quand t-rex a fait son
apparition il ya 65 millions d'années
une mer intérieure peu profondes coupe
et l'amérique du nord en deux en pêchant
le tyrannosaurus de rejoindre la partie
est du continent
le premier t-rex était la récompense
d'un chasseur de dinosaures réputé
barnum brown il a découvert en 1900 et
cn louisfert fields bronn qu'il a
baptisé les deux hommes travaillaient
pour le musée américain d'histoire
naturelle
à l'époque de cette découverte les
fossiles de dinosaures attirait déjà de
vastes foule
c'est leur taille qui impressionnait on
n'avait jamais rien vu de pareil
ces fossiles n'était pas complet mais
l'imagination issue play largement cette
version filmée d'une bataille entre
t-rex et le tricératops de la naissance
à un monstre aux proportions mythique
nos l'image demeura vivaces pendant la
plus grande partie du siècle
de nos jours jack rohner conservateur du
musée des montagnes rocheuses à bozeman
dans le montana fait partie d'une
nouvelle race de scientifiques qui
mettent en question les idées reçues sur
les dinosaures
c'est au début de 1990 qu'il a commencé
à soupçonner t-rex d'être un imposteur
tout a débuté par la visite de cathy one
qu'elle qui lui apportait los d'une
patte antérieure trouvaient dans la
partie est du montana
c'est ce qui permit à rooney de
découvrir le squelette plus complet de
t-rex
il fallu employer les grands moyens pour
mettre à jour les impressionnants
fossiles enterré depuis 65 millions
d'années les eaux servir de point de
départ à un sculpteur match mais pour
reconstituer l'animal le tyrannosaurus
rex exposé au musée des montagnes
rocheuses mesure une douzaine de mètres
de long
ça c'est une reproduction au 1 20e la
position des vertèbres dorsales et des
côtes est correct vu de l'arrière on se
rend compte que l'animal était plutôt
étroit il est arrivé qu'on imagine t-rex
comme une créature pataude traînant sa
queue sur le sol ce nouveau modèle
pouvait poursuivre sa proie à environ 50
kilomètres il aurait été plus rapide
qu'un homme lancé à fond mais ron
n'étaient pas convaincus que t-rex
mérité sa réputation de terrifiants
prédateurs
quand il trouva le premier tyrannosaurus
rex barnow rapportant le spécimen et
henry vers fidèle aux bornes fut la
première personne à l'étudier et bien et
lui donnant un nom qui signifie roi
tirant des lézards et il a estimé que
c'était un prédateur mais son
affirmation ne s'appuyait sur rien il
n'avait pas fait le travail nécessaire
pour le prouver il a déclaré que c'était
le plus grand animal carnivore jamais
découvert et on en conclut un peu
hâtivement que c'était un prédateur
cette conclusion rapide poussés à
imaginer t-rex comme un chasseur
sanguinet mais hunter en avait une autre
image celle d'un animal nécrophage
grandi trop vite une espèce de vos tours
gigantesques se nourrissant de cadavres
il admet que sa description de t-rex
n'est pas populaire
[Musique]
pour que les gens ne souhaite pas
entendre dire que le tyrannosaurus était
nécrophage pour une raison ou pour une
autre il est très important pour eux de
savoir surtout que c'était à prédateurs
la réputation de chasseur de t-rex
s'appuie surtout sur sa taille mais
comme le vautour l'un des plus grands
oiseaux carnivore il pouvait utiliser
son apparence pour faire fuir d'autres
animaux et s'approprier la nourriture
corner le compare avec un groupe de
dinosaures prédateurs qui comprend le
velociraptor le 3e dont et le deuil
nonick us tous bâtis pour la vitesse si
on pouvait créer un prédateur bipèdes on
prendrait pour modèle le velociraptor il
à la cuisse et le fémur cours mais c'est
long il ya celui donne un avantage pour
courir c'est pourquoi une autruche qui a
pourtant la taille d'un homme court
beaucoup plus vite que lui
le fémur et le tibia humains dont la
même longueur et le tyrannosaurus rex
avait également un fémur et un tibia
longueur identique
pour la première fois le prestige
qu'avait connu t-rex comme prédateur
semblait en danger mais très vite un
autre tyrannosaurus rex plus grands et
plus puissants à les relever le défi
[Musique]
l'absence de végétation dans cette
région aride du dakota du sud
en fait un endroit idéal pour y chercher
les os d'animaux disparus
[Musique]
peter larsson chasseurs de fossiles pour
le black l institute a trouvé les restes
disperser de nombreux dinosaures bec de
canard
ces animaux végétarien était la
nourriture favorite du tyrannosaurus rex
et en 1990 l'équipe de larsson mis à
jour le plus grand t-rex jamais
découvert après l'avoir examinée dans
leur laboratoire de il s'était il
conclure qu'il s'agissait d'une femelle
tyrannosaurus
en effet elle ne possédait pas l'offre
liée aux organes sexuels du mal et qui
lui permettait de les rétracter madame
t-rex fut baptisé chou en l'honneur du
membre de l'équipe qui l'avait
découverte
sow est légèrement plus grande que le
spécimen exposé au musée des montagnes
rocheuses non seulement chaque os est un
peu plus long mais il est également plus
épais le squelette tout entier donne une
impression d'une plus grande robustesse
de nouveau l'image du tyrannosaurus rex
était mise en danger par l'apparition
d'une reine tirant des lézards qui le
dominaient nettement ce n'est pas
quelque chose d'exceptionnel que la
taille d'une femelle dépasse celle du
mal on en trouve des exemples dans
beaucoup d'espèces chez la plupart des
invertébrés des poissons des amphibiens
chez beaucoup de reptiles et même chez
quelques mammifères
seuls les mâles des espèces qui se
battent pour s'accoupler avec plusieurs
femelles deviennent plus grand souhait
ses congénères ont vécu ici pendant 2
millions d'années à la fin de l'ère des
dinosaures
si l'on en croit fils cris joyeux noël
muse yom du canada à cette époque la
région et est luxuriante et plein de vie
[Musique]
en cette partie du monde de l'habitat et
le paysage devait ressembler à ceux des
états du golfe où toute la floride du
nord aujourd'hui il y avait une grande
diversité d'environnement des rivières
des espaces découverts des marécages etc
c'était un très bon endroit pour le
tyrannosaurus il pouvait trouver leur
nourriture dans différents habitats et
avait certainement de bons terrains de
chasse
car il nous dit que la région était
favorable à t-rex parce qu'il n'avait
aucun mal à y trouver des proies dans le
même environnement vivait de vaste
troupeau de bec de canard et de
dinosaures à cornes qui lui fournissait
sont énormes aux rations de viande
quotidienne sur la montagne aux oeufs
dans le nord du montana jacques renard a
trouvé un amado
où il a pu comptabiliser environ 10000
bec de canard
ils ont été enterrés par une éruption
volcanique bien plus dévastatrice que
celle du vésuve qui a enseveli pompéi
pour orne eure cela constitue la preuve
que tyrannosaurus se nourrissait de
cadavres les bec de canard et les
dinosaures à cornes se déplaçait en trou
pour gigantesque on peut se référer à
l'afrique d'aujourd'hui où d'immenses
troupeaux de bêtes sauvages se déplacent
ils sont suivis par des animaux
décrochage comme les hyènes et les
vautours alors on imagine mal des
centaines d'animaux bourran et les
tyrannosaurus ne devront pas les
cadavres
ça semble vraiment improbable on a
trouvé des dents de t-rex parmi les
ossements de bec de canard et de
dinosaures à cornes dont les troupeaux
parcourait les plaines du crétacé
supérieur mais phil curie et puis de
larsson ne sont pas d'accord avec la
théorie de reuil hn
la vérité c'est qu'aucun animal les
chasseurs à 100% ou nécrophage à 100% si
un lion trouve un animal déjà mort il va
le manger
s'ils ne trouvent rien il va chasser
le tyrannosaurus et les autres
théropodes devait avoir la même attitude
le tyrannosaurus n'aurait pas laissé
échapper un repas s'il rencontrait un
animal mort ils devaient le dévorer mais
dans le cas contraire ils n'attendaient
pas qu'il y en ait un qui meurt devant
ses yeux quand ils avaient faim il
chassait la question de savoir si le
tyrannosaurus chasser ou manger des
cadavres n'est donc pas tranché mais
larsson et ses collègues sont sûrs
qu'ils n'hésitaient pas à attaquer ses
propres congénères sous portent des
blessures qui le prouve une de ses
comptes ici près de l'épaule n'a jamais
guéri correctement et à l'intérieur dans
cette exhaust hausse qui s'est formée
dans la région affectée
on a trouvé un morceau de dent d'un
autre tyrannosaurus rex
sow a été mordue et a certainement dû
défendre sa vie plusieurs fois
larsson a également découvert qu'on
s'était occupé d'elle elle porte la
trace d'une fracture à une pâte qui
s'est ressoudé cela signifie qu'elle n'a
pas pu marcher pendant une longue
période et qu'elle n'a pu survivre que
si un autre t-rex lui a apporté à manger
mais plus tard affirme larsson elle a
été tuée par un de ses semblables
[Musique]
sans craintes portent des blessures qui
n'était pas guérie
l'os derrière son oeil était
complètement écrasé la partie gauche de
sa mâchoire étaient arrachés et pendait
sur le côté je pense qu'elle a été
victime d'un autre tyrannosaurus rex la
taille et l'état de conservation de ces
ou laisser penser qu'elle allait fournir
la réponse à quelques questions sur le
mode de vie et la façon de se nourrir du
tyrannosaurus rex
mais avant qu'on puisse sérieusement
l'examiner la malchance vous lui
conviennent l'enlever
[Musique]
le 14 mai 1992 des agents du fbi à y
pénètre dans les locaux du black et l'
institute afin de mettre sous leur
protection
plutôt larsson avait payé 5000 $ aux
propriétaires du terrain sur lequel on
avait trouvé sous mais ce lieu se
trouvaient à l'intérieur de la réserve
indienne de la rivière cheyenne une loi
fédérale interdit aux étrangers de
passer des contrats avec les indigènes
et d'emporter des antiquités sans avoir
obtenu la permission du gouvernement
fédéral
le procureur ordonne à la saisie dessous
ainsi que des photos et des notes qui
avaient été prises depuis sa découverte
[Musique]
des habitants de la ville étaient
furieux qu'on leur enlève la principale
source d'intérêt local pour leur
souhaite enfermé dans un container et
nous ne l'avons pas vue depuis plus de
deux ans il peut se passer des années
avant que quiconque ne la revoit nous
nous battons pour la récupérer et nous
n'abandonnerons pas avant d'avoir épuisé
tous les moyens à notre disposition il
faut qu'elle revienne au musée
d'histoire naturelle de black isle un an
et demi après sa saisie la cour d'appel
fédérale a rendu un arrêt contre larsson
et le black et l'institute il fallait
que ce soit rapportée au propriétaire du
terrain sans se décourager
peter larsson a continué à chercher
d'autres spécimens de t-rex en 1992 et
la mise à jour un squelette moins
complet baptisé stable
pendant ce temps là les prises de
position de jack warner continuer à
alimenter le débat
comment un monstre à la gueule aussi
impressionnante avec ses dents en forme
de sabre pourrait-il être autre chose
qu'un tueur
[Musique]
quand il trouva le premier t-rex en 1900
barnum brown était persuadé avoir à
faire un prédateur c'était en tout cas
le plus grand dinosaure carnivore jamais
découvert le crâne monstrueux de t-rex
semblait destinée à tuer conçu pour être
résistant il était en même temps les
jets de larges trous dans son crâne
réduisait son poids mais la structure de
la mâchoire étaient renforcés de muscles
puissants et il était capable de broyer
les os de n'importe quel animal
[Musique]
voici la mâchoire d'un vrai
tyrannosaurus rex
une de ses dents immense est encore en
place une autre est fixé là sur le côté
on voit très bien la racine et comment
elle est plantée dans la mâchoire
c'était une machine à tuer une machine
qui pouvait même broyer la patte d'un
autre tyrannosaurus rex jackson n'est
toujours pas convaincu que ce soit pour
chasser ou pour dévorer les cadavres
t-rex avait besoin de ses mâchoires
puissantes aux dents redoutable pour
déchiqueter la viande et il s'intéresse
à une autre partie de l'anatomie de
t-rex ses pattes antérieures minuscule
qui intrigue les paléontologues depuis
si longtemps avec le montana rex en
heure à trouver le premier bras complet
d'un tyrannosaurus on constate que t-rex
mesurait environ cinq mètres de haut et
que son bras n'étaient pas plus grand
que celui d'un homme en heure a demandé
au sculpteur matt smith de reconstituer
cette patte antérieure en utilisant la
musculature d'une variété d'animaux et
d'oiseaux existant aujourd'hui une étude
de biomécanique du bras ainsi obtenu a
montré que l'animal pouvait soulever 200
kg beaucoup plus qu'on ne l'imaginait
jusqu'ici les bras sont néanmoins bien
chétif pour une bête pesant 7 tonnes en
heure en a conclu qu'il était
pratiquement inutile pour capturer une
proie
le petit bras du tyrannosaurus rex
n'atteignait pas sa gueule pas plus que
les deux bras ne pouvait se toucher
alors imaginez que vous essayez
d'attraper un poulet avec les mains
attachées derrière le dos est impossible
un bipède a besoin de stabiliser sa
proie et le tyrannosaurus rex en était
incapable il paraît évident que les
pattes antérieures de t-rex était moins
efficace que celle d'aller aux russes un
dinosaure qui la précédait et qui lui
ressemblait si on compare les membres
antérieurs du tyrannosaurus rex avec
ceux d'un dinosaure carnivore plus
anciens la halle aux russes on voit que
ce dernier possédait une espèce de main
utile un prédateur celle du
tyrannosaurus rex devenu plus petit est
certainement plus spécialisés mais ce
qui semblerait prouver que t-rex était
un prédateur et le développement de ses
sens
un grand dinosaure carnivore doit
pouvoir trouver ses victimes
potentielles
n'importe quand et n'importe où et t-rex
avait cette faculté
il possédait une ouïe très développé lui
permettant de suivre une proie
de plus à la verse de la plupart des
autres dinosaures sa vision était
stéréoscopique
il enregistrait le moindre mouvement ici
on observe ses yeux on remarque qu'ils
sont très grands et le lobe du cerveau
qui se rapporte à la vision est
également bien développé de plus ils
sont dirigés vers l'avant et comme ceux
des humains ils ont une vision
stéréoscopique
c'était très utile un chasseur beaucoup
moins un animal n'est qu'en face le
globe oculaire est minuscule vraiment
très petit toriques des animaux comme le
velociraptor ou le troodon avait des
yeux énormes l'ouverture pour les
recevoir est immense mais pour un
carnivore l'odorat était sans doute plus
important que l'ouïe et la vue et t-rex
pouvez suivre la trace de ces futures
proies mortes ou vivantes
le lob du cerveau correspondant à
l'odorat est très développé on l'a
découvert en passant un de ses cousins
au scanner le nar mot tyrannus il avait
un odorat puissant qui aurait été
complètement inutiles s'ils s'étaient
nourris de cadavres nous humains qui
avons un faible odorat pouvons sentir de
très loin un cadavre en train de pourrir
rappelez-vous dans jurassic park le type
qui dit ne bouge pas et le tyrannosaure
ne te verra pas eh bien on admettons
qu'il ne puisse pas vous voir il pouvait
certainement vous sentir mais pour en
heure les lobes important du cerveau
correspondant à l'odorat ont une autre
signification pour un animal qui se
nourrit le cadavre
l'odorat et le sens le plus important
[Musique]
si on compare la taille du lobe l'oeuf
actifs à celle du cerveau on s'aperçoit
que son importance est exceptionnel on
ne rencontre son rapport de taille chez
un autre animal le vautour
certains doivent prouver que cette
dispute sur les préférences alimentaires
de t-rex a très peu d'importance que ce
ne sont que des figures de rhétorique
qui n'affecte pas notre vie actuelle
mais il faut penser aux millions de gens
dans le monde qui s'accroche à l'image
terrifiante que hollywood leur a donné
de t-rex
[Musique]
si on prouve que ce n'était qu'un animal
nécrophage la réputation du monstre que
nous avons appris à aimer risque-t-elle
d'être perdue à jamais
en 1994 jones terreur paléontologue à
trouver un autre t-rex dans la province
canadienne du saskatchewan
il faut rappeler qu on avait découvert
seulement neuf tirs ex entre 1900 et
1990 et puis on a mis à jour trois
squelettes assez complet en l'espace de
quatre ans l'importance accrue de la
paléontologie a fait naître des
vocations de chasseurs de fossiles
peut-être saura-t-on bientôt si t-rex
ressembler aux monstres qu'on a imaginé
aurait-il pu être un gigantesque
vautours préhistorique actuellement sa
réputation n'est pas encore ternie pour
la plupart d'entre nous il demeure la
caté sens dinosaures le seul l'unique le
légendaire tyrannosaurus rex
[Musique]